c'est m
indicateur de nous
on entend des questions à l'écran ou pas
pas forcément alors d'accord
s
je sais pas si je deviens de plus en
plus incisif parce que je suis de plus
en plus vieux ou parce que les échéances
se rapprochent ou à cause d'un mélange
des deux ou à cause et cetera ou parce
que moi j'en sais rien je considère au
savoir un peu plus longs et donc il ya
des trucs pour fini par accepter un peu
mieux en tout cas c'est évident qu'il ya
un certain nombre de sujets pour
lesquels on est dans une course contre
la montre donc plus le temps passait
finalement pour les gens qui
s'intéressent aux sujets plus on a envie
de
d'être pressent dans l'invitation à s'en
occuper
c'est toujours ça vous là
c'est un coup bas en ce qui concerne les
sujets énergie climat le problème a
commencé en fait étonnamment il a déjà
commencé depuis le premier choc
pétrolier ce qui a commencé depuis le
premier choc pétrolier par exemple c'est
l'accumulation des ti l'endettement des
états n'existait pas avant 74
ça va de cette époque la titrisation
dont on a beaucoup parlé au moment
crise subprime aux etats unis c'est
quelque chose qui s'est développée au
début des années 80 et ça a été une
réponse du système déjà à la difficulté
croissante d'avoir
une vraie croissance économique entre
guillemets sur la question du climat
ce qui s'est passé il ya pas longtemps
au maghred a pour origine notamment pour
seulement mais notamment des événements
météorologiques qui sont déroulés dans
le monde en 2010 et qui ont contribué à
affaiblir la quantité de céréales
disponibles sur le marché mondial c'est
aussi lié à la contrainte sur le pétrole
qui fait que les états unis convertisse
une fraction croissante de leurs
céréales en agrocarburants vous avez
déjà un certain nombre de pays la chine
par exemple qui connaissent des
sécheresses de plus en plus grave et qui
sont parfaite cohérence à risques est
attendu dans le cadre vraiment qu'ils
seraient chauffe donc en fait tom
urgence
pourrait presque dire que les parades
devant nous et déjà pour partie derrière
selon vous quelles sont les politiques
peut-être les états qui commence à la
fin il règne sur les généreux quotas
alors là vous me posez une colle parce
que je n'ai aucune idée du degré
sérieuse de prise en compte de ce genre
de sujet par les états d'abord au sein
d'un état un état sein d'écosystèmes
donc il ya des gens qui sont prêts et
concerner d'autres sont beaucoup moins
si par exemple vous avez un ministre
alors qu'il est important ministre b qui
dit qu'ils s'en fichent
est ce que l'état l'état prend pas en
compte donc je
j'ai beaucoup de mal à répondre à cette
question parce que ce que je peux dire
c'est qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'endroits où il se passe des choses
mais que pour le moment le rythme de
l'action n'est pas à la hauteur du
problème une véritable inadéquation
entre
contre cet espace entre ce que l'on vit
on a un petit peu comme si on était en
lévitation
sur une planète qui je veux
est-ce brute l'assomption
il n'y a pas une solution s'il y avait
une solution ça serait beau il ya un
ensemble de sujets
je
j'ai reçu
ça serait extrêmement prétentieux de
dire qu'il ya une solution parce que les
pays sont ces divers qu'ils ont des
cultures diverses des ressources
diverses des marges de manoeuvre
diverses
pour prendre un exemple parmi d'autres
aujourd'hui les pays qui ont énormément
d'énergie renouvelable dans leur
approvisionnement
on soit beaucoup de forêts par personne
soit beaucoup de montagne par personne
simplicité biblique le vent ne pèse pas
grand chose c'est l'hydroélectricité la
biomasse qui représente l'essentiel de
l'énergie d'origine renouvelable ce qui
a conditionné les marges de manoeuvre
dans ce domaine par exemple si la
géographie
vous avez d'autres domaines dans
lesquels la force agricole d'un pays par
exemple c'est le fait que ce soit ou pas
aux moyennes latitudes avec des pertes
arabe et de bonne qualité qui en général
sont situés dans l'ancien bassin
sédimentaire
c'est très peu une affaire de volonté
des peuples et beaucoup une affaire de
géologie et de géographie le la solution
au problème elle n'est pas unique par
contre ce qui est unique ce le fait que
l'on peut pas agir contre un problème
qu'on n'a pas identifiés donc si on
connaît pas son ennemi on peut pas agir
contre et là en l'occurrence un mal qui
est commun à toutes les démocraties
c'est une insuffisance de connaissances
partagées entre les électeurs les élus
et les gens qui sont au milieu c'est à
dire les vidal
mais la formalisation d'un rapport de
force à est-ce que vous avancerez des
cours complets
on attend comme s'ils
droit international il vient en fin de
processus et pas en début on a fait
l'onu parce qu'il ya eu la sga renault
la seconde guerre mondiale est conseillé
quand même il faut qu'on trouve un moyen
d'éviter de se taper dessus
on a fait l'europe exactement pour les
mêmes raisons c'est à dire que après le
conflit on s'est dit plus jamais ça et
donc on va faire quelque chose qui
permettra d'éviter le propre couronne se
reproduise donc le droit international
c'est très rare dans l'histoire des
peuples il est précédé la première
manifestation d'un problème
en général il a plutôt suivi pour éviter
que ça se reproduise avec le changement
climatique on est dans une situation
très particulière parce que le problème
ne se produira qu'une fois qu'il aura
pas de répétition du problème et au
moment où on commencera ont constaté des
effets est considéré comme insupportable
la seule certitude qu'on aura à ce
moment là c'est que ça s'empire derrière
à cause de l'inertie du système
climatique parce que l'essentiel de
l'inertie du système climatique et dans
l'océan pas dans l'atmosphère et l'océan
est un truc très inerte qui changent pas
d'avis une fois qu'il a décidé de partir
dans votre direction donc le là là toute
la difficulté dans cette affaire-là
quelque part c'est d'avoir peur de
quelque chose qui ne s'est jamais
produit et de tout faire pour que ça ne
se reproduise jamais c'est une solution
phare commentaire c'est une situation
pardon que
il ya eu plus simple à gérer pour le
droit international qu'est ce que c'est
au juste
c'est forcément une guerre question
parfaitement inéquitable
il n'y a pas une seule définition du
chaos c'est pareil ce qu'un français
appellera le chaos peut être une
situation parfaitement sympathique pour
un habitant d'un autre pays qui depuis
des dizaines d'années connaît la famille
de la guerre donc le chaos on va dire
que c'est un état de dégradation fort de
la situation par rapport à son
commissaire pourquoi est ce que c'est si
difficile de changer les choses après
nous avoir un martyr mais un habitant
plutôt à la campagne donc plutôt à la
ville et pas forcément travailler toute
la journée concours après le
un revenu de plus en plus élevés c'est
peut-être plus séduisante du concours
presque une attente du bialé le
mimétisme est quelque chose de
particulièrement fort c'est avec ça
qu'on élève nos enfants et c'est avec ça
que les sociétés se soudent s'il y avait
zéro mimétisme et qu'on n'était qu'une
bande d'individus sans aucun sens aucune
pensée commune sans aucune envie
d'imiter le voisin et cetera en tant
qu'espèce on n'aura jamais survécu
sauf que aujourd'hui cette envie de
faire comme le voisin à partir du moment
où on est collectivement pris dans
quelque chose qui n'est pas durable
bah ça se retourne un peu contre nous et
c'est quelque chose qui est susceptible
de nous amener des ennuis significatif
mais il ya une partie de notre code
génétique qui joue contre eux
ce n'était pas facile j'attends du banc
est ce que vient des politiques qui
appellent pour
vous consultez pourquoi tous les
conseillers jamais les clients de notre
société sont essentiellement des
entreprises
on a extrêmement peu de collectivités
locales comme clients à notre grand
regret mais c'est lié à quelque chose de
très particulier que connaissent très
bien les gens qui travaillent avec les
collectivités locales
si la procédure d'appel d'offres notre
métier est un métier dans lequel on doit
si je dois employer une expression très
pompeux très pompeuse pardon penser
l'impensable
et l'impensable savais pas qu'on crée
des charges ce que vous mettez dans un
cahier des charges c'est du connu connu
et archi connu et archi revue donc si
vous voulez amener de la rupture par le
biais d'un appel d'offres c'est juste un
système qui est pas fait pour ça donc on
ne travaille pas avec les collectivités
locales à cause de ce système là et en
ce qui concerne les élus nationaux les
élus nationaux de demande jamais rien à
personne sauf quand vous commencez à
avoir votre nom partout dans ce journal
et à ce moment il demande à monsieur
machin ou madame truc de s'occuper d'un
problème bien particulier mais ça
devient une mission ça devient pas une
commande au sens d'une commande rémunéré
où on paye pour faire un boulot c'est en
vous demande votre avis sur un sujet les
étudiants de sciences po
alors je ne connais pas les étudiants de
sciences po parce que je me renseigne
pas donc je n'ai pas d'avis sur
l'évolution des interventions